あんな古いやり方をするなんて
バカバカしいなおお道元元気じゃないよな
どうした
会社だよ
新しい仕事任されたんだけど
会社のパソコンと
会社の今までの古臭いやり方じゃないと
ダメだって言われてるからもう全然進ま
ないもうだからダメなんだよね日本はそう
かそれは大変だなでもね一応悪いけど今の
FAXを使わなきゃいけないんだよもう何
年だって思ってるあいつっていうかそれ
だけじゃなくてお客さんと
全く意味のない飲み会にも行かなきゃいけ
ないし
本当に日本だけがこんなに効率の悪いやり
方をする国ってそうだな
FAXと全く意味のない飲み会は良くない
けどねだろっていうか教えてなんで日本人
は飲み会で
絶対にお箸上手ですねっていうわけお箸
って日本にしか存在しないって思ってるの
みんないや道元フラストレーション溜まっ
てるのは
すごく伝わってくるけどあとそれ最近日本
人は外来語使いすぎているイライラしてる
のはすごく伝わってくるけど今の道元の
発言はどうかと思うよお前もFAXを使う
の好きじゃないからコースを道元の発言は
良くないと思うよ意味わかんないし道元が
今の状況に不満を感じてるのはよくわかる
し
俺も同じ立場だったら同じように不満を
感じると思うけどだからダメなんだよね
日本はとか日本人っていつもこうだよねっ
て
物事を一概に言うのは良くないよ
俺の会社だって日本の会社だけど
FAXを一切使わないし嘘でしょ外国人が
お箸を使ってるところを見ても何にも言わ
ないというか今の若い人のほとんどはそう
だと思ういや若い人にも言われたことある
よだから何人2ってこと今
若い人全員日本人全員口ぶりで話してるよ
道元でも未だにFAXを使っている国は
日本だけだよ絶対にそしてその傾向に抗っ
ている日本人のいくらでもいるそうかも
しれないけどじゃあ答えて日本っていう枠
に誰が入ってる日本人だろじゃあ日本在住
の外国人は日本の一部じゃないんだね
別の扱いにした方がいいんだ違う日本に
住んでる人全員だだったら未だにFAXが
存在するのは道下の責任でもあるいやそれ
は違うこれは確かに日本に住んでるんだ
けど
普通の日本人と全然違う考え方を持って
全く話を聞こうとしてくれないだからダメ
なんだよね外国人は今なんて言ったお前